ما الذي سنخسره في حال فقد ناتر ان يروا
الشركه مشاهدينا سيكون كارثه جيو سياسيه
ليس فقط على الولايات المتحده ولكن ايضا
على العالم الديمقراطيه وفق ما تحدثت عنه
مجله فرن بوليسيه في الولايات المتحده على
سبيل المثال الحسابات الاخباريه على تويتر
تراجع حضورها واحتمال زوالها هذا الامر
يتحمل مسؤوليته بشكل مباشر مالك تويتر
الجديد الماسك منصه تويتر ليست كنزا وطنيا
لكن لابد من الحداد على المشهد الجاري في
الشركه لانها كانت عاملا قويا لابراز
الطابعه الديمقراطيه على مدار الجيل
الماضي تقول المجله الامريكيه
قبل تويتر اي من في الثمانينات تحديدا
كانت الاخبار في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يهيمن عليها كليا عدد صغير من
الشركات بدءا بما يسمى الصحف الوطنيه مثل
نيويورك تايمز ودوستري جورنال عشان تبوسط
وحصل معظم الامريكيين على اخبارهم من ثلاث
شبكات تلفزيونيه وطنيه مثل سي بي اس وان
بي سي واي بي سي بعد صعود وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بشكل عام وتويتر بشكل خاص تم
تدمير نظام المعلومات القديمه واصبحت
المنصه منبر للجميع سواء افراد عاديين او
شركات كبرى واصبح بامكان الجميع مواكبه ما
يجري حول العالم سواء في افريقيا او شمال
شرق اسيا او دوائر التاريخ الاكاديمي في
الولايات المتحده وغيرها من المجالات
العلميه والطبيه والثقافيه والفنيه بشكل
موثوق والاهم من ذلك جوده المعلومات التي
يتم مشاركته اعتبارات خالص لان البدائل
الجديده تويتر ليست وعده ومن الصعب
استبدال من التقدمت للملايين نظاما نخبويا
واستحواذ ماسك على المنصه يهدد بتدمير هذا
النظام ودائما حسب فرن بولسي